was mir aufgefallen ist in diesen videos
die ich dort gesehen habe wird auch
erstmals wenn auch erstmals wieder
begriffe gewählt die ihm gegenüber
homophob sind ich habe da gehört das
schwule sau gerufen wurde vermuten sie
dass hinter diesen anfeindungen auch
homophobie stellt weil wir sehen halt
bei solchen situationen immer dass das
kein anderer auch wie dünn manchmal die
decke ist über die wir da so gehen oder
der ferne so wie man es nennen will
das dann in solchen situationen eben
doch auch alte stereotype vorurteile
beschimpfungen schimpfwörter wie wir sie
kennen dann wieder wieder hervorkommen
und schnell zu ihnen gegriffen wird ich
finde in solchen momenten spürt man
immer wieder manchmal die decke ist über
die wir so gehen wo wir insgesamt im
glauben als gesellschaft eigentlich
schon weit gekommen zu sein was was etwa
die frage der gleichberechtigung von
schwulen lesben allen angeht sind wir
doch noch nicht so weit wenn wir diese
bilder sind wie wir denken na ja wir
sehen jedenfalls dass das alles schnell
relativ wird offensichtlich in so einer
stresssituation für einige und sie dann
schnell auch wieder zu solchen wörtern
greifen aber ich bleib dabei eins ist
mir echt wichtig damit da jetzt auch
nicht irgendwie sondern so ein mythos
entsteht die ganz große mehrheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger trägt erstens mit
die maßnahmen der bürger der
bundesregierung auch wenn da manche
persönliche härte ist und manche härte
im alltag selbst auch da wo einige
fragen haben sagen sie im großen und
ganzen ist der kurs richtig und ich
erlebe auch bei denen dies kritisch
sehen
das ist meistens dann nicht die
schlagzeile wert ich erlebe auch bei
denen dieses kritisch sehen in den
allermeisten situationen die möglichkeit
zum gespräch das habe ich in den letzten
zwei drei wochen wo ich viel unterwegs
war sehr oft gespürt dass da eine ebene
ist auf der man dann doch ein gespräch
führen kann und deswegen finde ich darf
man sich halt jetzt von diesen
situationen die wir gerade gesehen haben
dies auch ein paar anderen städten
gegeben hat aber die darf man jetzt
nicht verallgemeinern das wäre ein
falsches bild der gesellschaft